Sarah to Zachariah lives in hope she's
looking for the names of her children on
lists from refugee camps in the eastern
Nigerian city of yola but the search
today is in vain Naomi gaggia rahmatu
and Abraham aged from seven to fourteen
and not to be found tsunade if they're
still alive may God take care that I get
to see them again if they are dead I
will see them in heaven but I pray that
God gives me strength so I may find them
alive yeah Bernie husky tonina monokuma
hai na yun doesn't even occur udg more
than a year ago Boko Haram fighters took
Sarah to and her children from their
village eight months after their
abduction Sarah two alone managed to
escape she shows us on a map the area
she's already covered while looking for
her kids 14 refugee camps in northern
Nigeria and Cameroon the search has been
dangerous well they're not going through
not sharing my travels I saw how the
military court Boko Haram fighters were
only able to charge him I recognized one
of them how do you then it all came back
I was shaking and almost collapsed a
soldier asked me what's wrong but I
didn't dare say anything don't y'all
worry let you bother I sukma takashi
logically sorrow to is still traumatized
from the time spent in captivity she was
separated from her children shortly
after their abduction
it's not do a cooking killed men right
in front of our eyes afterwards they
said to us women we have killed all the
men none of them are alive and we will
do the same to you if you don't convert
to Islam who said listen Christianity is
the false religion of the whites well in
my buckle to Hurley be ideally Sarah to
did not convert she now gets support
from her community the bishop of yola
has organized a service for the refugees
here they pray for the more than 2,000
women and children taken by Boko Haram
and for those left behind like Sarah too
there's no kind of spirit that I can
admire more than that of this woman I
can't just imagine the kind of
perseverance and the heart that she has
four children at a blow disappeared and
for one and half years and this woman
has not broken down Sarah to won't give
up she says that as soon as she gets
some money she will set out once again
to find her children